[Musique]
c'est des choses qu'on voit jamais
d'exigeant tirer comme ça en l'air et
surtout ma le sentiment qu'en discutant
un peu avec les temps le quartier autour
et regarder tout ça qui condamnait on
apporte de quoi ils sont idiots ils pour
les voitures de leurs propres quartiers
de notre quartier c'est absurde
par contre le sentiment général c'est
quand même une incompréhension face à
l'inaction des forces de l'ordre samedi
à dimanche quand enfin ce groupe e le
comité de cette chaîne n'est pas là d un
quartier ils ont laissé déambuler et
taper sur des gens au hasard
moi qu'est ce que je constate c'est plus
en plus graves
voyez ça va pas en diminution c'est
qu'il ya quelque chose ça monte et c'est
plus en plus graves
alors où tu sais qu'on va aller comme ça
moi je pensais pas quand même qu'il y
avait encore quand j'ai vu tout les uns
et ça sort du bizarre mais c'est déjà
passé des jeunes des grilles victoire
jusqu'à ce que j'ai vu là - mélange dit
comme elle dit c'est pas possible
les crazy son bénéfice moi hier soir
j'ai entendu des explosions dans la nuit
une heure du matin chez détailler les
été obligé que ce qui se passe au brésil
ça se déplace sur la zone de chez nous
parce qu'à mon avis c'est la même
population est scellé c'est les mêmes
jeunes qui semblent à l'acide qui peut y
avoir de plus mauvais sur le pays et
c'est vrai que moi ça m'interpelle parce
que je me dis mais jusqu'où on va aller
à vix a à faire attention aussi qu'il ya
très souvent en des idées des enfants
dans la rue on se parle des enfants
en bas âge des femmes et que forcément
on a peur et que on veut absolument pour
protéger on n'en veut plus sortir
je veux te la maison moi perso qui n'ont
pas vraiment très très compliqué hein